alors vous savez où nous sommes
on est sur le domaine archambault qui au
19e kilomètre au tampon
c'est une parcelle d'environ un hectare
8 qui a été acquis par le département en
1900 soit 97 alors il faut savoir que
sur cette parcelle nous avons sans la
partie avant une maison au style du 19e
siècle maison créole avec juste devant
un jardin d'apparat et juste à l'arrière
se trouvent une forêt on va dire semi
première qui a été cliqué conserver
actuellement car on se trouve dans une
zone urbaine donc tous l'importance de
la conservation de ce patrimoine
alors il faut savoir aussi que cette
maison est l'ancienne maison de
villégiature de l'ancien maire de saint
pierre
monsieur augustin h en bout qui venait
passer des vacances ici donc nous par
rapport à au site
le département a décidé de réhabiliter
cette maison alors nous avons fait bien
entendu des diagnostics sur la structure
il s'avère que la structure est vétuste
donc on doit déconstruire cette à
déconstruire et reconstruire la maison à
l'identique c'est le projet et du
département pour cela bien entendu nous
avons fait des consultations de maîtrise
d'oeuvre et là on est en phase de
consultation des entreprises
alors concernant l'aménagement nous
avons une salle principale qui se trouve
juste devant la maison à l'entrée qui
est destiné à une salle multi-usages
faire ce site est destiné à recueillir à
recevoir du public scolaire des
touristes
et puis du public en général donc on
aura ce qu'on appelle des expositions
des ateliers pédagogie et d'explication
sur le site et sur ce site nous avons
aussi d une association qui intervient
le g7
nous avons des ouvriers à chaque équipe
et dans l'aménagement c'est prévu
d'avoir des vestiaires par rapport au
code du travail donc il faut que
les aumôniers puisse avoir un certain
confort par rapport à leur activité sur
le site
nous aurons aussi des locaux de
rangement
parce que les ouvriers on a besoin d
outils tout ce qu'il dit piochez
débroussailleuse ça on a aussi un
endroit de stockage plus générale aussi
dans ce site
on a ce qu'on appelle le boucan qui se
trouve juste à l'arrière du bâtiment
principal qui était comme son nom l
indique l'endroit où on faisait cuire à
manger donc ça ça va être transformée en
galerie reviendrait donc à but
pédagogique bien entendu on a déjà
installé des ruches forêt pour pouvoir
extraire le bien et bien cette mairie
sera une vitrine on va dire 1 par
rapport à aux différentes étapes de
fabrication y met du miel sur ce site
il
alors archambault aussi on peut
retrouver la pépinière com
ce site a pour objectif aussi d'être un
site pilote pour les trois ânesses de
lille un fort beau donc constitue lui
aussi un vivier de
deux plans de plantes endémiques élevé
donc en pépinière est suivi par un
pépiniériste
donc quand tu gsm voilà donc qui sert de
vivier donc pour la restauration
écologique sur nos sites divers sites de
l'île et n'est donc que son activité est
aussi prenante que l'entretien de la
forme rios